[Music]
[Applause]
he's uh the lead broadcaster and he's
the managing editor at vegas stats and
information network raiders play-by-play
voice and uh one of the great
broadcasters in history's mr vegas he's
brett mosberger joins us on the program
good morning brent how are you good
morning dan i'm fine how are you lad i'm
going i'm doing well how much money did
you have on last night's game
[Laughter]
let's say i have to still continue
working
[Laughter]
yeah my tie didn't
probably my worst pick of
of the year but i guess nick saban has
to lose a big game every now and again
it was an interesting game uh you know
far different from many of the
college championship games that we have
seen but listen hale georgia and
speaking of georgia what about what that
state has done they win the world series
with the braves and now they win the uh
national college championship you know
with the bulldogs and uh what's wrong
with the falcons you know what i mean
yeah that's not that's not going to
happen anytime soon there little
pressure on the atlanta hogs do you have
a limit on how much you bet
oh yes absolutely i mean i'm a strictly
a recreational better i would i would
have been busted long time ago if i
tried to make a living out of it
i
listen i'm more of a hundred dollar
better than a thousand dollar better
okay uh
that's what i that's what i would say
dan best bet you ever made
best
bet
i ever made
probably was on
at most recent was certainly
the writers on last sunday's game when
we uh
we went far end of the night to finally
beat the uh the los angeles chargers
that certainly is the most the most
recent one that i've been able to catch
and i also had the raiders over seven
and a half wins i thought that was a low
total for them yeah going into the
season uh but i had to sweat it out in
the end and of course with their their
win streak at the end of the season they
did go past and wound up with ten
victories i'm trying to understand the
fallout from the chargers raiders game
that that the criticism that brandon
staley is receiving
do you think the raiders were going to
play
for the tie
well i think the
possibility existed okay
uh
i don't think they wanted to put carlson
on the field for a uh
you know nearly a 60-yard field goal
however
i really don't blame
staley and the chargers for that time
out and i
they failed to execute when josh jacobs
got loose on that last run i mean
somebody could have stepped in there and
made the tackle
and then it would have been up to the
raiders to make the consideration i i
certainly think
uh that they were thinking about it over
on the sideline because
if they had missed
a long field goal at that instance with
a handful of seconds left
then you certainly would have given
herbert
one final chance to push it down the
field and he was he was magnificent in
the fourth quarter but
but you know staley want to adjust his
personnel on the field the linebacker
that he took out murray
has been a bit of a disappointment to
the chargers and he took himself out of
the game earlier in the fourth quarter i
just happened to notice that from up in
the uh up in the radio booth they wanted
to get him out for a stout or run
defender and it didn't work out jacobs
jacobs made the cut
and and they didn't execute but i
honestly don't
i don't we don't know what would happen
if they hadn't called the time out and
kept the pressure the one thing that the
raiders did do after the time out which
might have made it easier for jacobs
a car head lined up was going to be on
the shotgun before the chargers called a
timeout and then he moved up underneath
center that allows him when he pivots
to hand off jacob's going to be moving
at a higher rate when he hits that line
and that may have helped uh jacobs
explode and then and then pick up the
additional yards and they were able to
bring carlson out for the tight end
i honestly blame staley moore for his
fourth and er eight at fourth down going
for it back on his own 18 yards i
thought that was
completely arrogant now we didn't score
a touchdown
after that we did pick a field goal and
i
i i think listen i understand analytics
but you don't win games with analytics
you want it with human beings and you
had the better football team i don't
think there's any question
demand for man the chargers have better
talent
and more experienced talent down the
line so you go ahead and punt that
situation and uh and let your team
take over right i thought that was the
biggest
mistake that he made not necessarily
that the timeout that everyone seems to
be talking about but al davis hat would
be rolling over in his grave if he knew
the raiders played for a tie and allowed
a divisional opponent to make the
playoffs like nobody's talking about
that brent that the raiders i guess gave
consideration to play for a tie
exactly and can you ima dan can you
imagine what was going on in the city of
pittsburgh yeah i mean it was it was
past midnight and if the game had wound
up in the ties you say a division
opponent the chargers would have also
gotten into the playoffs there's one
there's one other thing that you should
consider about the uh
the raiders decision and i'm assuming
that the coaching staff knew about it
if the raiders had tied the chargers and
both had gone to the playoffs
the raiders would be going to kansas
city this week and not cincinnati now
i'm not taking any away from cincinnati
joe burrow a marvelous young quarterback
okay
but the raiders they wanted they want no
part of the kansas city chiefs again i
mean the chiefs have put 40 points on
them in each of their two victories with
this season so so obviously they would
prefer to go to cincinnati although the
bengals i've got to point out the
bengals put 31 on them in las vegas and
burro didn't even throw for many yards
derrick carr made a couple of big
mistakes in the fourth quarter and the
bengals pounced on it and uh
and won the game rather easily but i
think
any coach would say yeah i think i'd
rather go play the bengals there's a
question about that injury that borough
suffered a couple of weeks ago rather
than go in and face the chiefs i agree
brent i brought that up yesterday i'm
like people are missing a bigger story
here you don't want to play kansas city
because they've blown you out both times
and yes you have to go cross country to
play against cincinnati but cincinnati
they're newbies getting into the
playoffs here uh like you want to play
for the win i had people who said this
yesterday you know the raiders still
hold a grudge against the pittsburgh
steelers and they would have tried to
keep the steelers i'm going these
players now have no idea what the hell
happened with the immaculate reception
i mean come on
they want to keep pittsburgh they won
pittsburgh i'd rather face pittsburgh in
the playoffs than i would the chargers
so
you know for sure for sure because
remember now the raiders went to
pittsburgh
first of the season and they beat the
steelers in in pittsburgh certainly no
doubt about it that i don't think that
prospect ever entered into their mind i
don't think so either you have to be
selfish you have to be selfish down on
the sideline and uh
and so be it i mean
i will tell you that josh jacobs from my
mind played his best game of the year uh
he has not been completely healthy and
it showed up on that run
and then you know daniel carlson has
been the iceman and uh you know five
game winning kicks my goodness what a
year he's had as a kicker and and so be
it and it's i'm happy for derek carr he
finally gets to uh play in a in a
playoff game the last time the raiders
made it he was a quarterback but he
suffered a broken leg
week 16 he did not play down in houston
and the texans eliminated the
eliminated the raiders but it'll be
interesting because you know dan as you
so well know the the cincinnati bengals
have had that long playoff drought okay
you have to
i don't even know that boat johnson was
in the nfl the last time the bengals won
a playoff game so uh that's a long long
time ago and uh we'll see what happens
i'm sure the city is very excited
i can't wait to see my favorite
restaurants who are jeff ruby speaking
of guys like the wager on football games
jeff
jeff is a degenerate better i mean he
he he frequently texts for information
what do you think this week what do you
think
uh we're talking to uh brent mussberger
he's the voice of the raiders they have
the game with the bengals coming up this
weekend
uh you know all these tributes to uh
john madden i forgot that
you were was that at the rose bowl that
you you uh worked with john when you
were at cbs
yes uh it was at the rose the super bowl
it was a super bowl and it was the rams
who were playing the steelers and
to give you a background uh we had
signed john and
we weren't too sure if he was going to
be better in the studio
or doing games and so we put
john up on the roof and
he was talking primarily about the
steelers the afc and we also signed
george allen
and he was going to talk about the nfc
so i had both of them up on the roof and
by the time i got finished i said the
van gorden solder who was our uh
the sports fashion man
john madden's got potential to be a star
he's just so entertaining when he talks
you never know where he's gonna go
uh and and you listen carefully to him
and he was a star upon the uh up on the
roof that day there was there was no
doubt about terry bryce on the stairs of
course
defeated vince farage i'm on the rams
and um and won that particular
super bowl and another thing about john
is that bangalore desire
rather than start him out with
pat sumrall or vince kelly who are our
two lead play-by-play guys
he put him with gary bender
and gary bender really really taught uh
john madden the ins and outs of working
up at a booth and it was such a good
relationship and then
when the debate began as to who uh
madden would work with
uh van again made an outstanding decent
van initially wanted him to work with
vince scully and uh then he was talked
out of it by several people on the staff
who felt that that john would have more
breathing room working a booth with
summerol and it was a it was a fantastic
decision because the uh the rest is
history john is john one of the more
entertaining people that i've ever been
around we we finished up our nfc
coverage we didn't have the super bowl
one year in chicago and
john of course was riding the train then
a lot of people thought he was fearful
of flying that's not the case he was
claustrophobic and uh
we always had a room in a hotel either
the third floor or lower foreign but i
but i kind of felt sorry for him headed
to the train station and i said john let
me let me cancel my airplane reservation
we'll take the train back to new york
and of course was the winter time
i'll never forget we had two breakdowns
one in upstate new york and i think we
got into grand central about 16-18
however so i left i said john i love you
my man
you're great but i just took my last
train trip back from my football okay
oh yeah he was uh danny he was a delight
what what a great life uh you know first
of all uh one of the more entertaining
coaches why did he retire at 42 though
brent
well i think he was exhausted
uh
and and listen part of it was still a
claustrophobia i mean claustrophobia
includes not wanting to get into a
tightly
uh controlled airplane up in the air
okay i mean that that was not a small
part but he
he felt he'd done what he'd done and uh
it was time to move on and uh you know
we had the two sons and and uh a great
family man and and so
uh even though he took a shot at
broadcasting didn't know anything about
it uh hadn't paid a whole lot of
attention to it and
was able to come in and be the most
dominant analyst certainly of our time i
i tell young i i tell young analysts i
said listen
the one thing that john did
better than any analyst is didn't start
talking right away he used his monitor
they they failed to understand that the
camera sees so much more than the naked
eye and week after week after week i
hear these guys
jump in and they really don't know what
they're looking at okay last night there
was
uh there was chaos in the early going
what appeared to be for example a
georgia touchdown on a fumble and then
uh the truck you you have to be very
patient and john always was because you
wait for that right
angle to come back which showed clearly
that bryce young's arm was moving
forward last night and uh and john was
john was outstanding and then we had a
cameraman at cbs that john madden
controlled
and during the game he would look for
those
sidebar stories um you know what's under
the bench and what kind of gloves were
players wait wait how did he control the
cameraman well he was the one who would
tell the truck uh go over to you know go
over to the cowboys bench i look behind
it i see some things over there that
look interesting he would tell the truck
during commercial timeouts to send the
sideline cameraman to look for those
special
especially but if the game was close dan
important and things were going back and
forth he didn't worry so much about that
but john madden was the greatest ever in
a blowout okay because he looked for
those sidebar stories that kept you
entertained
gave you a chuckle going forward of
course he invented thanksgiving
uh with the turkey presentation uh after
the game and those those were ideas that
came from john madden and also he was
the first analyst who insisted
uh that there was a meeting the night
before the game i know of pregame
meetings in which uh the crew was
actually in there for about three hours
look at a tape with john and he would go
over different things he he was a
teacher as much as anything else when uh
when he worked back in the days at cbs
as our top analyst
always great to catch up with you good
luck uh this weekend against the bengals
and uh we'll catch up with you soon
thank you brent
you got it dan take care of my man
that's brent mussberger hall of famer i
can listen to those stories
you know sometimes you forget stories
that you have and brent's been around
you know since the early 70s it's like
al michaels
they just have incredible memories